a historic move years in the making to
protect our wild horse and burrow
population not only in nevada but all
across the west the u.s senate
appropriations committee has earmarked
more than 10 million dollars for the blm
to use fertility control rather than
roundups madison kimbrough has the story
for decades the bureau of land
management has resisted controlling wild
horses with fertility and instead using
force the helicopter roundups are
horrifically cruel these animals suffer
significantly during the process wild
horse advocates like gann vice are
hopeful that that could change now that
there is an appropriations bill
providing 11 million dollars for
fertility control it could help move
away from the current roundup program
that lands thousands of horses into
holding pins it's very traumatic for the
horses
many of them suffer from broken necks
broken legs to hold the agency
accountable blm must report back within
45 days with its strategy for a
vaccination initiative in a statement
the agency said the blm makes every
effort to conduct gathers in a safe and
humane manner every attempt is made to
place them into good private homes but
no comment on the current initiative
which was just announced fertility
control vaccine
provides a humane alternative that is
also very cost effective
to allow these animals to stay in the
wild where they belong madison kimbrough
live local now
blm's current management plan is to
remove 90 thousand horses and burros
from public lands by the year 2025.